An increasingly pressing issue
is rapidly spreading across the globe.
Our world isn't evolving
only due to the passage of time.
It's changing rapidly because of our own actions.
We often find ourself turning a blind light to
our surroundings,
to the very environment that stain us.
It's concerning that even today,
some people still contribute to environmental.
A simple injustice
can be the seed of a much larger problem.
Consider how even the smallest option
can cause significant problems.
Isn't it unbelievable?
Some people seem oblivious to their surroundings,
continuing to commit injustices
as if they are unaware of their consequences.
In this New Year,
even new generation,
according the words of the perversaries of
who once said that you is the whole of the nation.
It becomes a responsibility of signal to share ideas
and options that can bring about meaningful change.
But it's not just the youth who should take actions.
It's important that each one of us take actions,
actions that contribute to the betterment of our
environment,
benefiting both our surroundings in our lives.
Let's stay step to
ensure the well being of our environment.
She fades beneath.
The power of change lies within us.
Let justice and peaceful.